what is he
the first one where it all began was in
the 1890s the story of daniel robitaille
he made a good living tour in the
country painting portraits for wealthy
families but you know how it goes
they love what we make
but not us
robitaille committed the ultimate center
for stein
they fell in love
they had an affair she got pregnant
the girl tells her father what
you know
he hired some men to hunt robert tied
down and told him to get creative
chase him through here in the middle of
the day
he collapses from exhaustion right near
where the old tower and chestnut used to
be
they beat him torturing him they
cut off his arm and jab a meat hook from
the stomach they smear honeycomb from
the nearby hives on his chest and let
the bees sting him a crowd started to
form to watch the show
the big finale
they set him on fire
and he finally dies
but a story like that
a pain like that
lasts forever
that's candy man
[Music]
so
[Music]
he's real
bell is real samuel sherman
daniel rubin ty they're all real
candy man is how we deal with the fact
that these things happened
this is still happening
[Music]
you